During a break in the PE exam, an
engineer unwraps a Nature Valley granola
bar.
Upon the first bite, the bar behaves as
expected and explodes into thousands of
crumbs that scatter across the testing
center.
The mass of crumbs is determined to be
log-normally distributed with a
geometric standard deviation sigma g of
3 mm and a geometric mean crumb diameter
of 5 mm.
Approximately 86.4%
of the crumbs are expected to have
diameters less than what size in
millimeters?
So, this is a short problem statement
that can potentially lead down a long
rabbit hole if you're like me and bad at
statistics.
Let's walk through it in a simple way,
describing only what you need to know.
The problem statement mentions that the
particle mass is log-normally
distributed.
Searching the reference manual for
normal distribution returns one section
that we can use.
Page 172 provides a normal distribution
function
being given as z equals
x minus mu over sigma.
Being log-normally distributed means
that the logarithm of the particle size
is normally distributed.
Therefore,
when applying the z-score equation,
we can replace x with natural log of x.
Now, let's define our other terms.
In the context of a normal distribution,
the letter z represents a standardized
score or a z-score.
It measures exactly how many standard
deviations a specific data point is away
from the distribution's mean.
A z-score is a statistical measurement
that tells you how far away from the
mean or average your data lies in a
normally distributed sample.
Mu is the mean of the normally
distributed values.
Since this problem is log-normally
distributed and gives us the geometric
mean,
we can convert between the two using mu
equals ln of X sub G.
I also forgot to note before that the
term X is the observed value, or in our
case, the crumb particles.
Sigma is the standard deviation of the
logarithmically transformed values.
Since the problem gives us a geometric
standard deviation, we can convert using
sigma equals natural log of sigma G.
Now that we've made this distinction
about some of our terms,
we can fill them all in in the equation.
Z will need to be pulled from the normal
distribution table a few pages away.
In this table, the standardized variable
is labeled X instead of Z.
Since this is a standard normal
distribution with a mean of zero and a
standard deviation of one, the table's X
values are equivalent to Z-scores.
We have to know that Z
is actually the column here labeled X
and that we are looking for the values
to the left of the curve, which is the
column labeled capital F of X.
Looking the capital F of X column for
0.864,
we find a corresponding X value of
approximately 1.1.
In a standard normal table, this X value
is equivalent to the Z score.
So, as we go back to filling in this
equation, we will leave X blank for now.
Our geometric mean, X sub G, is going to
be 5
as is given in the problem statement.
And our sigma G value, originally sigma,
from the original equation, is going to
be 3.
Next, we can rearrange the equation
and then simplify by applying a given
logarithmic property given in chapter 7.
We can then apply one of the other
logarithmic properties and rearrange the
equation so that we are finally left
with X equals 5 * 3 raised to the 1.1.
Otherwise, calculate it out to 16.74.
Leading our closest answer at the top
here to be our final one of 17.
So, the big takeaway here is not
necessarily the final answer.
It's knowing where to find the normal
distribution section in the reference
manual and recognizing that log normal
distribution problems are really normal
distribution problems in disguise.
Once you can find the Z value from the
lookup table and understand how
geometric means and geometric standard
deviations fit into the equation,
the math itself is fairly
straightforward.
If this problem felt long and annoying,
remember that now you know where this
normal distribution table is in the
reference manual, as well as some
logarithmic properties, as well as
identities from chapter 7.
And that's it.